- Let's recap.
(fans screaming)
- We just met the whole
Stranger Things cast, hello!
- They were all wearing make-up.
- Why are you being so chill?
This is not a chill moment.
(upbeat music)
♪ Get ready like one, two ♪
♪ Three, four, wow ♪
- You guys wanna hangout?
♪ It's so good ♪
♪ Got me up on this feeling ♪
(ambient music)
- This is the best day of my life.
I can die happy now.
- So overwhelming.
- You can clickbait this!
- [Tour Guide] Welcome
aboard ladies and gentlemen,
appreciate y'all coming
on the tour with us.
- We're about to start the tour, right?
- [Woman] That's right.
- [Tour Guide] Just tryna
check the sound balances
of my microphone.
All right, we're getting
ready to make a right turn
on Highland Avenue right here.
Now what you seeing in front
of you is the Dolby Theatre.
Dolby Theatre is where
the Oscars are held.
(upbeat music)
- We were supposed to
go see the Dolby Theatre
but we missed the turn, I guess.
This driver doesn't
really seem to know much.
- [Tour Guide] Forgive us.
As I said, this is our main voyage,
got stuck in a loop here a
little bit but bear with us.
- What is happening?
- [Man] Aww, that's so cool!
- What's that?
- Hawkins
- [Tour Guide] Ladies and gentlemen,
we're gonna have to stop.
(electronic music)
(screaming)
- Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Listen to me, listen,
listen to me, listen to me.
I'm local law enforcement
in this part of town, okay.
You're clearly near Hawkins, Indiana.
So why don't we go take a
stop and get some ice cream?
Does everybody like ice-cream?
Driver, can we go around the corner?
- Jim Hopper yo, Jim Hopper!
- Can we go around the corner?
I gotta ice cream spot I wanna stop at.
(electronic music)
- [Interviewer] How are
you feeling right now?
- Very good!
- We got there and we
all had panic attacks.
I was just so overwhelmed,
like I can't believe that they were there
and we got to see them in front of us.
- [David Harbour] Hey guys, guys!
Do you guys wanna get some
ice cream at Scoops Ahoy!?
- This is so much better
than what I thought it was gonna be.
- [Woman] I thought I was
gonna die on this tour.
- C'mon everybody off the bus,
everybody has to eat ice cream.
Look at this!
Literally oceans of flavor!
Now listen, we're gonna
have to say goodbye
for like three minutes.
(crowd chattering)
Come Joe, come Gaten, come.
Come, come, come, come, come!
(upbeat music)
(crowd chattering)
All right listen, for those of you
who said I wasn't your favorite character.
(crowd screaming)
I have a couple new
employees from Scoops Ahoy!
(crowd chattering)
- Literally my favorite show for two years
and I literally can't.
- I got a call from
their principal last year
that Emily got caught watching season two.
- I watched it in my
photo class, my study hall
and in my math Class,
and my principal found out
and got really mad at me,
and they tried to take my phone.
- We pretty much give you guys ice cream
is what I'm thinking.
- [Woman] Okay I want some.
(upbeat music)
(crowd chattering)
- Hi, how are you?
Oh I love you both!
- [Interviewer] How are you feeling mate?
- I'm shaking!
- [Interviewer] You're
flipping out, aren't you?
- Thank you!
- [Gaten Matarazzo] I did it again!
Nah, I didn't even do it before.
- [Joe Keery] That's okay!
- Actually, it didn't tip over
so we're good.
- Amateur.
Give me one of these bears!
- [Fan] Milly Bobby Brown handed me
an entire cup of toppings
and I didn't know what to do.
- [Photographer] Everybody turn around,
we're taking a big photo!
A big photo will be taken.
- Okay, we have to have the tickets!
We can't take the picture
without the tickets!
- Oh yeah, we got the
passes right, for tomorrow?
(crowd screaming)
- You guys are going to the premiere!
- We're in disbelief right now
because of what just happened.
When we saw David, like c'mon now!
- I'm tryna process this in my head
- [Woman] It was worth missing work today
- Yes, thank you guys really!
- June 27th folks, a day
we will never forget.
- Yeah.
- That's right.
I'll tell you that we're living it!
(crowd cheering)